hello everybody my name is mark employer
and welcome back to three scary games
[Music]
this is bad ben featuring nigel bach as
tom riley
cool
[Music]
how the [ __ ] do i move interact tablet
situational awareness mechanic
okay what is a situational awareness
mechanic
the following footage was retrieved from
the residence of thomas riley
a home he had just purchased
at a sheriff's sale
oh
okay
all right let's see what i've gotten
myself into all right they told me the
previous owner mysteriously disappeared
and they mentioned something about a
tablet and security system too uh-huh
god damn it
yes
[ __ ]
okay all right okay
all right okay
who interested
[ __ ]
can i get that key that looks important
[ __ ] can i get that nah
nah no way
[ __ ] nah i can't get it what do you have
to say about that god damn it i know i
know man it's tough
[ __ ]
all right okay what am i doing i've
completely forgotten exactly what i was
supposed to do i kind of ignored the
whole objective oh interesting this is
glowing i'm assuming that this is
important
here's the tablet that controls the
security system let's see if the camera
and motion sensors are all working i'm
guessing not
god damn it
all right so
it's going to walk around blindly until
i hit something
oops [ __ ]
god damn it
this
i've never known how much i wanted a
button that just did that god damn it
[ __ ]
all right anyway time to get serious
what is it doing trying to okay
first floor seems to be functioning in
the living
room let's see all right we're good
there
yes
okay
okay got that what about in here
yes
all right
that takes care of the first floor and
now i have the second floor to go to
what a load of [ __ ]
[Music]
damn this house is a real pizza
what do you think of this statue here
[ __ ]
all right i'm stuck hang on
all right
good
good good okay i can't open any of that
can i run no i can't run i would never
run with the tablet
this hallway makes me feel like [ __ ]
i'm sorry
that takes care of this floor
now to check the basement now to check
the basement i'm sure that
i'm sure that this is gonna go
god damn it
[Music]
that was probably nothing probably
nothing probably nothing i'm not gonna
worry about that
no way
no way man
i'm stuck
here we go
[ __ ] it's locked i guess i better search
the house for some keys i mean it's like
i'm in a lazy horror game made by a bad
developer
[Laughter]
oh interesting
looks like the camera uh
the camera quality is a bit like this
yeah i know man
let's go try this key out yeah let's go
try this key out
what's going on over there in that
corner
by that table something's like slightly
transparent it's weird
nope that's not the right key there must
be more somewhere son of a god damn it
son of a [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ] hey wait what's with this
baby hey there was this baby there
before uh i don't know about that i
think in the living room there might
have been something i have no idea
let's see let's see
now i was mistaken where did i see
another key i know i saw another one but
once the first one didn't work i didn't
really pay attention to any of the other
ones
aha
that's where it was maybe this key opens
the basement maybe it do and winner
winner yes
that's not the right key better key
eat my
sounds like something fell over upstairs
hang on i'm trying to say something eat
my [ __ ] nope well yes well no
[ __ ]
all right whatever that joke's getting
old what fell down up here who fell over
who did what baby
well i'm just gonna get on out of here
key
maniki
interesting what the [ __ ] yeah that's a
box just filled with keys i don't know
what [ __ ] this i'm going to bed i'll
deal with this tomorrow that's a good
that's a good idea man i'm not even
going to bother with that i'm not even
going to bother not even gonna bother
turning around or looking at my tablet
or discovering what that guy was doing
in the corner over there it ain't no big
deal he's just in time out
i'm going to bed is this bed
is this my bed
bedroom two master bedroom downstairs
i don't know about the whole concept of
a first floor master bedroom but
whatever
great now what sounds like that came
from the other side of the house um
interesting
i better go investigate too bad this
thing doesn't actually give me any
indication of what's happening in any of
the rooms
i know
i know man i'd love to go through this
doorway
oh
grandma's ashes
is this grandma's ashes what the [ __ ] is
this
are these
ashes
damn it it's in my shoes and i'm not
wearing socks i have someone else's
ashes in between my toes well why did
you step on it man where did this come
from
oh oh
what the [ __ ] who cut the power
god damn it is someone upstairs you
better get out of my house you little
[ __ ] yeah this guy's got the right
attitude about
things happening in your house you know
it's really
it's really refreshing [ __ ] i love it
i really do love it i respect this guy
very much something about this guy just
commands authority
how am i seeing
i guess
oh
i'm not gonna deal with that
i'm not gonna play with that no thank
you
no thank you all right who's stomping
around up here
yes who
boom it's
i better
i better close that window [ __ ] i better
it's cold
it's cold as [ __ ] in here
oh i think the fuse box is in the
basement this [ __ ] messing with me
must be down there hmm
must be
mosby
[ __ ] must be down there
hmm
[ __ ]
god damn it
this
hmm well that was a strange noise that
i'm not gonna investigate at all
not your home [ __ ] is that blood
not your home why got news for you it is
my home looks like this subtle blood
trail leads to the basement
looks like the basement is open looks
like i can't be down there you little
[ __ ] it's you and me now yeah it's you
and me now toward me kicking your ass
is this is that a wily coyote was that a
wily coyote like image on there
oh
all right i'm recording this now get
ready for the ass kicking of your
eternity of uh the ass-kicking of an
eternity the ass kicking of your life
oh my god it smells like [ __ ]
someone living down here well doesn't
look like anyone is here now let's see
if i can get that camera fixed uh yeah
let's see if i can get that camera
doesn't look like it has any power
um
maybe it has something to do with this
plug
there let me check the camera now let me
check the camera now
god damn it what's wrong with this thing
[Music]
he's real sneaky i gotta give him that
he's real sneaky
my head
that [ __ ] the previous owner didn't
disappear he's been living down here the
whole [ __ ] time where did that [ __ ]
go my hat
it's time for some payback yeah it
assumes okay i'm back
i'm back minor blood stain on my head it
don't matter it don't matter it's time
for payback [ __ ] oh the hell did this
yes what an [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh i'm gonna tear you a new god damn it
oh my god
ah smart this guy intelligent rational
reasonable i'm gonna get out of here
apparently
goodbye everybody
uh
i gotta get the [ __ ] out of here i gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here
i'm getting the [ __ ] out of here
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going on
i'll back out
that'll get me gone okay
interesting
i'm just slipping on out of here
oh oh come on
can i go in here
okay
oops
hold on all right
looks like nowhere to go but up i hope
i'm ready for whatever's up
beware
who's in here
[Music]
be aware of what comes after the
demarcus
[Music]
oh my god that addict was the craziest
[ __ ] i've never seen so many hot ghosts
in my life man that was like the
highlight of this whole experience
anyways moving on
moving on to what
oh boy okay all right then
hmm interesting
fascinating
interest oh
well then
oh
i'm in no
yes
[ __ ]
not everyone who says to me lord lord
will enter the kingdom of heaven but i
don't want to be there
[ __ ]
oh hello
oh
hmm
uh-huh
god i love this
[ __ ] oh you don't say that
i'm gonna go sit in this chair
you sit in this chair i've been naughty
oh
ah
[Music]
that's how it began
oh
is this like a game that's based off of
like some home movie that some dude made
and they got him to voice this this is
so fun i love that so much
i love that
i i genuinely it's so silly but also i
really love it
i really loved it it was great
that was fantastic
i thought that was phenomenal
that was great
boat physics
intimacy coordinator
meet wizard dong modeler don physics
simulations i'm waiting for the after
credit sequence because this does seem
like it would have one i
you know i'm good i'm good i'm good i'm
good oh great that's great that's
wonderful
i love that
what do you mean shotgun
what
all right let's see what i've gotten
myself into
they told me the previous owner
mysteriously disappeared no oh no hard
quit okay thank you that was fantastic i
love that in every way but also what the
hell
okay well
moving on
[Music]
this is good boy
and apparently it's my birthday
and i was asked if i was a good boy
i don't honestly know
it's my birthday today
oh that's it
oh
oh what
what
this is not what i was expecting
it's a picture of me
what
[Music]
hi kitty hi mr mittens
an old toy box
gifted to me by grandma
e to interact with objects
what the hell this is so much different
than i was thinking it was gonna be
okay
a bookshelf full of stories that grandma
reads to me
it is my birthday today
okay
what the hell i love this
i
love this
this is so cool
oh hi uh
there's my sleepy birthday boy got all
tuckered out from playing with the cats
this morning didn't you
i gotta go
i got i gotta go i gotta okay
why don't you stay in here and play
while i go finish up your special
birthday dinner i'll call for you when
it's done
okay bye
and i gotta go there's this weird red
glow over here that i thought might have
been the way i was supposed to go but
you know i guess now that i'm thinking
about it the weird
this door
oh
oh i don't like that door
huh
this goes to show it does not take too
much to make to like elevate something
and make it stylized
oh shoot
oh shoot wait oh no did i game break did
i break the i break the i broke i broke
it i broke it i broke it i don't think i
was supposed to go through the door i'm
100 sure i broke that uh i'll be right
pretend it never happened erase it from
their memories
[Music]
okay bye mom i'm assuming mom mom i'm
assuming mom okay i'm gonna keep playing
hi
hi twinkle toes
a picture of grandma
okay i don't know exactly how to play i
don't feel like watching tv well that's
not right
a pumpkin a baby pumpkin
[Music]
ball
ball ball ball
ball ball
i'm gonna go for the high score
well this is just so much fun
i tried to have mr mittens picture of me
and mom
a picture i drew of mr twinkles
it's dark oh birthday boy your dinner
almost ready why don't you go get a
grandma and tell her so she doesn't miss
you blowing out my candles any candles
okay
i'll go get grandma
this grandma's room where i think it is
i think grandma's room might be where i
think it is
hi grandma
grandma
oh grandma
oh where is it okay oh my god
[Music]
it's my good boy
my okay
hi grandma
my good boy it's your birthday isn't it
oh
yeah
you know how grandma loves your birthday
uh-huh
hehe i've left you a present in the hall
my good boy go get it
okay
okay i'll go get it okay grandma
thanks grandma
thank you grandma
oh
boy oh boy
oh i got it grandma
grandma i got it do i go back grandma
what do i do with the present grandma
[Music]
grandma i got it
i have it
oh god no wait stop do it i didn't mean
to that's not what my intention was
[Music]
i really i thought that i would talk to
grandma about the knife and the
president being a little bit weird i
thought that we
you think this is over i don't know what
anything is
oh i merely struck down the puppet not i
thought i struck down my grandma
and now i need a new puppet
oh oh
[Music]
oh that ain't good that's that's not
good that's what you would call not good
okay well i guess i'm
fine
[Music]
oh wow
[Applause]
simple but effective that's the thing
about it right it looks simplistic it's
like easy sketches like but it was the
effort and the placement of that effort
that made it something special i was
cool and like the moment going into
grandma's room that was a pretty
freaking scary moment and i liked that a
lot but uh i'm gonna leave the other
endings up to you guys but that was very
good link is in the description check it
out moving on
welcome to psycho unstable journey
odd name
and i have no idea what the concept is
except that you may be in a car
oh oh oh
i must have fallen asleep at the wheel
i'm driving
all right
well
this is my first move by car to another
city
before i always flew by plane
hope i get there quickly
and safely
i'm sure i won't jinx man
the weather is not very good today
it's night
oh [ __ ] it wasn't expected
need to refuel the car do i shouldn't i
have gotten fuel before i left if there
are gas stations here at all
i did not plan this very well
oh yes here's the gas station i need to
stop by
all right i will stop by
i crashed
i'm not doing good hang on hold on hold
on i'll pull up perfectly perfectly done
okay um
do i go here
hello do i go in do i pay first
hello
oh hi
don't mind your failing power this is a
lovely store you're a lovely human how
are you
uh hello
i need to refuel
um hello
are you here me
well thank you so much for your
patronage my patronage i'm talking to
you hello
she doesn't seem to hear me she doesn't
seem to see me either
she doesn't seem to a lot of things you
know
well
a goose
what is the goose what is the goose
doing here you know that's a good
question don't touch him oh you speak do
you
oh you talk
huh
uh what is the goose doing here
he lives here great do you live here
great why were you silent before
i've been busy
what did you do you just stood there do
you care what do you need i need gas did
you not hear me
just need to pay for the fuel
well
how much
41. great how do you know
did i fuel already okay go bye
goodbye goosey
bye lucy
what the what is the ghost doing here
okay goodbye
all right back on the road again that
was fine what the hell is this
i hope i don't get to this gas station
again i don't know why you would get to
it again
well back on the road
thought i saw a siren head
well this is good it's strange during
the whole ride i haven't met a single
car
anywhere in my backseat i don't even
have a backseat okay
i don't like all this
yeah me neither pal
something seems a little bit odd
what the hell happened i'm alive where
is the car uh uh
i don't know if i'm alive
i really don't know how far i could have
been thrown out of a car to land here
and be alive
so that don't seem likely
oh good oh good
oh where am i what kind of place is this
yeah a bad kind with gooses uh hello oh
that that that's not good
oh hey my eyeballs are screwing up a bit
um who are you
i am a resident of this forest i live
here
great
what are you doing here
now i'm warming myself by my fire i'm
going to have dinner
what are you going to have dinner with
what meet what you see in the trees to
my right
oh good
and what is it
this is meat by the way you will eat
with me oh
i'll probably refuse yeah i'll probably
refuse this is delicious
ah
okay maybe we'll eat tomorrow
you're gonna wait tomorrow for me to eat
with you
please engorge yourself on the pulsating
sack of spike meat
okay goodbye
i gotta go my car is mysteriously here
oh it's everywhere
god the meats are really blossoming this
season
my car is not damaged but how
back on the road again
i feel bad
it's all in your head
i feel fine i feel stronger actually
weird
oh
i think i might have taken a wrong turn
somewhere i seem to be dizzy do i
my eyeballs seem to be fragmenting into
different glitchy pieces
which is perfectly normal as we all know
i don't know why eyeballs keep staring
at me in the darkness or why there are
so many eyeballs in the darkness but um
oh god i am dizzy
the manta rays
okay what kind of bird is that
oh it's a wonderful bird
oh good
i think i huffed a few too many fuels at
the gas station back there
that goose was a little bit moist
okay
am i oh i'm dead
i'm live
off
beautiful day
gorgeous even gorgeous
oh my god i can't believe i got there
where
where are you
it was a very difficult trip but i got
there there where
where is there
how good that all this horror is over
how good
lorem
if anyone's gonna try to crash into me i
am so ready for it i'm so ready
you would never you would never you
would never oh
that's actually the end
as far as like unsettling goes i think
it was really trying to go for that and
it did it pretty good you know it did a
pretty good however it was a bit too
slow paced you know there was a little
too much of a gap between anything the
car was just a little too sluggish and
like not enough going on in the
environment that was like changing a
dynamic but i did kind of enjoy it so
not terrible not terrible and it's not
not terrible at all that was pretty okay
thank you so much for watching this
three scary games video
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you